>> YEAH, YOU STILL GOT YOUR
HENNESSY HIGH.
HE HAS GOT ALL THAT ADRENALINE
STILL PUMPING TO THE VEINS.
ABOUT 345 OR FOUR.
>> THEN GET TO WORK.
WHAT TIME DID YOU GET TO WORK?
>> 815.
MIGHT HAVE BEEN A LITTLE BIT
LATE THIS MONEY.
>> YOU HAVE ALREADY REVIEWED
THE FILM LAST NIGHT?
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN DONE
QUESTION MIKE
>> OH YEAH.
WE TOOK THAT DOWN.
BECAUSE OF COBIT, I DON'T THINK
WE ARE ALLOWED TO MAKE A TEAM
OR SOMETHING ALONG LINES WHICH
IS COOL.
WE STARTED TO BREAK ON THIS
HOME.
>> BEFORE WE TURN THE PAGE, WE
HAVE YET TO TURN THE PAGE AS A
SHOW AND THAT NATIONAL MEDIA.
LET'S DISCUSS.
WHAT WERE YOU ABLE TO DO LAST
NIGHT THAT YOU ARE MOST PART
PROUD OF?
>> TOM BRADY WHERE IT IS I AM
TRYING TO GET A GOOD HIT ON THE
BALL, WE ALL KNOW TOM REALLY
SLOWS AS FAST AS THEY COME TO
THE LAST COUPLE DAYS WE SAW
TREY ANDERSON GO AND TAKE AWAY.
ALL THE SERIES TO MALCOLM BROWN
AND GETTING A STACK ON HIS OLD
QUARTERBACK FROM THE PATRIOTS.
YOU KNOW IT WAS JUST ONE OF
THOSE THINGS WHERE DAVE SEEMED
LIKE HE HAD 12 PRESSURES LAST
NIGHT.
I THOUGHT WE DID A PHENOMENAL
JOB OF REALLY GETTING THAT AS A
QUARTERBACK. SHADOW TO THE
DELIGHT.
HE CAME UP WITH THE INTERCEPTION
FROM MARCUS DAVENPORT TO KICK
THE BALL TO THE LINE THAT HAD A
HAND ON THE PLACE.
>> TO ME, THAT LOOK LIKE A
VOLLEYBALL PLAY. YOU KNOW WHAT
I MEAN?
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
YES IT DID.
IT REALLY DID.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU GUYS AS A UNIT
WERE ABLE TO PUT IT OVER THE
NET.
HOW REPEATABLE IS THIS CAMERON?
IS THAT THE BEST WE HAVE SEEN?
OR, YOU SAY YOU CAN GET BETTER.
HOW REPEATABLE IS THIS?
>> I MEAN, IN MY MIND I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY IT'S A NEW STANDARD.
WE ALWAYS TRY TO DO BETTER
EVERY DAY.
YOU CANNOT GO INTO A GAME.
>> EIGHT.
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO HAVE TO
RUN THE IDEA OF THE GAMES.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU GO AGAINST
TEAMS.
THE BOXER WITH ALL THE WEAPONS
THAT THEY HAVE. I THINK WE JUST
PLAYED A OF A GAME LAST NIGHT.
I WOULD LOVE FOR IT TO BE THE
NORM THOUGH.
THEY COME OVER THEN ESPECIALLY
LOCATED.
>> CAMERON AND JORDAN HERE ON
THE RICH SHOW AFTER HE SAID BOTH
RACING.
THE BUCCANEERS ON SATURDAY
NIGHT BUT.
WALK ME INTO THE LOCKER ROOM
AFTERWARDS.
THE SATISFACTION LEVEL WAS
WHAT?
WHAT WAS THAT SEEM LIKE A SMART
WALK ME IN THERE FROM SI.
>> IT WAS A PARTY.
THE WIND.
WHEN THEY GO TO: WORKS HARD ALL
WEEK. THE NAME OF THE GAME IS
WINNING.
WHEN YOU ARE WINNING, THINGS
LOOK GOOD.
WAS IT GREAT TO SEE SEAN
DANSON?
ABSOLUTELY.
IT WAS A PHENOMENAL FEELING
BEING A PART OF THE TEAM AND
WINNING. THAT'S A FEELING YOU
CANNOT GET OVER.
>> THE FAMED EATING AT W TOOK
PLACE IN THE SUPERDOME MANY
YEARS AGO.
NOW HE IS DOING IT IN
CELEBRATION OF WHAT HAPPENED
AGAINST HIS FORMER TEAM.
EVEN NOW, IT IS STILL SOMETHING
THAT NEEDS LITTLE BIT OF AN ARM
TWIST FOR YOU TO SAY IT IS
FINE".
DID I JUST PICKED THAT UP CAM?
>> YOU GOT TO EMBRACE THE
SITUATION.
YES.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OKAY.
IT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU STILL
NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE MUSTARD
ON THAT OR LESS MUSTARD
ESSENTIALLY IS WHAT YOU SAY.
>> YOU KNOW, YOU CANNOT HIDE
FROM IT.
AS A TEAMMATE, I DO NOTHING BUT
SUPPORT MY BROTHER IN ARMS.
I DON'T KNOW, I WOULD LOVE TO,
IF HE NEEDS IT EVERY WEEK AND
WE ARE WINNING EVERY WEEK,
LET'S GO.
>> LET'S GO.
ALL RIGHT.
>> WELL, WE SAW THE RETURN OF
MICHAEL THOMAS LAST NIGHT.
YOU ALSO ARE GETTING GUYS ON
YOUR SIDE OF THE BALL BACK AS
WELL.
WHAT IS MARCUS DAVENPORT'S
RETURN MEAN FOR YOU AND YOU
MENTIONED TREY IS PLAYING HIS
HAT OFF LATELY?
WHAT ABOUT THAT AND HOW YOU CAN
USE IT MOVING FORWARD.
>> MARCUS HAD SOME GREAT
PRESSURE.
WE TALK ABOUT THINGS BEING ON
THE FIELD.
>> OF COURSE, LIKE YOU JUST
SAID TREY HANSEN IS PLAYING OUT
OF HIS MIND RIGHT NOW. HE WAS A
GREAT QUARTERBACK.
THAT'S LIKE WE LIKE TO SEE.
>> YOU TAKING BRADY ON THE HALF
OF YOUR TEAM OBVIOUSLY IS
SIGNIFICANT.
WHAT ABOUT ON BEHALF OF BRADYS?
>> THING IS GOING TO LIKE IT
WILL BE THE GREATEST CREDIT
BACK OF ALL TIME.
WE HAVE HIM IN TOM BRADY
FIGHTING FOR THE TOUCHDOWN.
THE TALK BUT DREW CLEARLY
HAVING MORE YARDS.
TALK ABOUT THE SEASONS HE IS
PUT TOGETHER."
REEDY AND HIS CHAMPIONSHIP
THERE.
THEN WE TALK ABOUT WITH THOSE
TWO.
TALK ABOUT MOST CHAMPIONSHIPS
WINNING. YOU HAVE THE ARGUMENTS
FOR ONE AND TWO.
GOING TO SPEAK TO MINE BEING
NUMBER ONE.
>> THOMAS BEING BACK MEANS
WHAT?
>> OH MAN.
MIKEY?
HE SPECIAL.
>> YOU SAW YOU KNOW.
TRUE WAS MORE OF A RECORD.
IT'S SUCH A BEAUTIFUL THING.
>> ARE YOU THE BEST TEAM IN THE
NFL?
>> I MEAN, WHAT YOU EXPECT ME
TO SAY HERE RICH?
WE ARE STRIVING TO BE AS BEST
AS WE CAN BE.
I WILL SEE, WE ARE TRENDING
UPWARDS.
I ALWAYS CONSIDER MYSELF AND MY
TEAM TO BE THE BEST THAT WE CAN
BE.
I WILL LEAVE THE IMMEDIATE TO
LABEL IT.
WE WILL JUST KEEP ON WORKING.
>> I WILL TELL YOU CAMERON, I
LIKE TO TAKE IT ONE SEGMENT AT
A TIME AND HOPE FOR THE BEST.
I LIKE TO FEEL LIKE I'M
BRINGING MY EGG INTO THE
MICROPHONE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I KNOW THERE ARE AMAZING SHOWS
ON THIS VERY CHANNEL AS WELL
FOLLOWING DAN PATRICK'S SHOW
EVERY SUNDAY.
I WILL SAY HAVE GOT THE BEST
SHOW ON TELEVISION.
YOU KNOW, WHAT YOU WANT ME TO
SEE IF I AM ASKED, DO YOU HAVE
THE BEST SHOW ON TELEVISION
QUESTION MARK YEAH I DO.
>> ANYTHING LESS?
WHATEVER YOU ARE DOING YOUR
PUTTING YOUR BEST FOOT FORWARD.
>> THEY HAVE A GREAT SEGMENT
HERE.
HAVE A GREAT TEAM THERE.
THEY HAVE A GREAT HOST THERE.
THAT HAS GOT MARCONI'S BUT I
WILL STILL THROW MY MARKER DOWN
. YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> VERSE ANYONE. IF YOU LIKE IT
I LOVE IT.
>> YOU TOLD DOWN THE SAME THING?
>> I'M TESTING YOUR TRUST LEVEL
RIGHT NOW CAMERON.
THAT'S WHAT I'M DOING.
I'M TRYING TO FIND IT. WHO IS
ON YOUR PODCAST NEXT?
>> WE HAVE GOT A STAR-STUDDED
CAST.
>> I NOTICED YOU HAVE THEM ARE.
ARE YOU DOING THEM DURING THE
WEEK AT ALL?
OR NO QUESTION MARK YOU DID
THIS BEFORE THE SEASON AND YOU
ARE RELEASING THEM ONCE A WEEK
BUT IS THAT WHAT IT IS?
>> WE ACQUIRED MOST OF THEM
PRESEASON.
THEN DRINK BY WEEK, WE ARE
GOING TO KNOCK THEM OUT.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS
POSTSEASON.
>> RIGHT NOW YOU ARE IN THE ONE
SEAT.
IT'S ONLY ONE BY WEEK.
THAT WILL BE VERY GOOD FOR YOU.
CONGRATS ON THAT W LAST NIGHT.
I GUESS EATING IT AND THE I
GUESS WHAT IS LAST, WHAT'S
TOUGHER TO ACHIEVE WHAT YOU DID
LAST NIGHT OR TO GO HOME TO
YOUR KIDS ON SHORT WEST AND
THEN NOT CARING WITH COVERT I
AM UPSTAIRS AND DOWNSTAIRS.
TRYING TO PROTECT THE FAMILY
AND TRYING TO GET THEM CARED
FOR THE NEXT DAY.
ONCE I GET THAT, I COME BACK
HOME.
THERE UP THIS.
>> KEEP DOING THAT CAMERON.
STAY HEALTHY.
STAY HEALTHY AND KEEP DOING
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
THANKS FOR THE CALL AFTER SUCH
A BIG WI